all right Patrick crazy is set to go on
trial later this month for the murder of
his fiancee Kelsey Bharath the story
first made headlines last year after the
Colorado mother disappeared on
Thanksgiving Day we now know Frazee was
having an affair with another woman
crystal Lee prosecutors allege the
secret relationship ultimately led to
the murder Niki batiste has covered this
case for nearly a year and she has new
details on the investigation in this
week's 48 hours Patrick Frazee has
entered a plea of not guilty in the
murder of his fiancee Kelsey Bharath as
a reminder Patrick Frazee is presumed
innocent until proven guilty Kelsey's
body has not been found and this
surveillance video of her grocery
shopping on Thanksgiving is the last
time she was seen in public kelsey a
pilot and her fiance Patrick a rancher
have a baby daughter
police say Patrick told them Kelsey
wanted to end their relationship he said
Kelsey wanted to go their separate ways
and they were just not meshing anymore
turns out there was another woman in
Patrick's life
a former Idaho rodeo queen named crystal
Lee what a crystal say about Patrick was
she in love with him I think she was to
a point
Michelle Stein says her best friend
crystal confided in her about a
disturbing conversation crystal and
Patrick had before Kelsey disappeared
she had told me that he had asked her to
take care of his baby mama and you took
that yeah so I was like well I was in
shock first because people who says that
and she said yeah he asked me if I would
kill the mother of his baby Michelle
says she pushed crystal to call the
police but she didn't and neither did
Michelle I kept telling her think you
need to call and tell somebody I'm
trusting her to do the right thing but I
think Michelle people-watching will say
call the police say now we did talk to
my hands
asking her to kill someone you're right
but do you ever gret of course I regret
it I regret it every day after Kelsey
vanished authorities tracked down
Krystal and when they offered her a deal
in exchange for her testimony against
Patrick she told an incredible story she
admits to cleaning up the crime scene
and tells the prosecution the whole
entire story of what happened there's
poison coffee there's a metal baseball
bat scented candles a blindfold phones
that are pinging all over Colorado and
in Idaho Krystal told authorities
Patrick tried to get her to kill Kelsey
three different times and each time she
chickened out then she says it was
Patrick who killed Kelsey the details
are chilly yeah so crystal Lee the the
girlfriend she was given a plea deal by
prosecutors do we know what was in it
yes so in exchange for her testimony
against Patrick freezy she agreed to
plead guilty to evidence tampering
versus a more serious charge so right
now she only faces a max of 3 years in
prison but the trials coming up if her
story falls apart that deal is off the
table
investigators believe her story and
prosecutors have her story to go on it
though how her phrases lawyers planning
to defend him against this they just
recently filed a court document saying
that they're gonna point the finger back
at Krystal that they say she may have
fabricated parts of her story or may
have even been involved in the murder
well what about their little girl we all
saw the video of Kelsey pushing her in
the in the heart Kaley is now 2 years
old she is with Kelsey's parents and we
spoke with Kelsey's mom in the hour and
Kelsey's friend she was a Pyatt pilot
and by all accounts a wonderful woman a
wonderful mother and right now Kelsey's
family is just hoping that her body will
be found they searched a landfill after
speaking with Krystal but found nothing
so it seems no leads at this point it's
a tough case there's no body there's no
murder weapon so it's really Krystal
story versus Patrick's at this point we
know you'll be on it and they keep it
East thank you very much you can see
Nicky's full report the murder of Kelsey
Bharath on 48 hours tomorrow
at 10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS